[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend in einer cdu sitzung warnte
angela merkel gestern wir haben eine
lage die alles übertreffen wird was wir
bisher hatten diese botschaft
überbrachte sie heute auch noch mal
denjenigen die nach ihrer
regierungsverantwortung übernehmen
wollen die spitzen der künftigen
ampelkoalition fuhren heute abend im
kanzleramt vor man darf vermuten dass
die gastgebende naturwissenschaftlerin
deutlich wurde aus berlin klaus brodbeck
es ist schon dunkel der kommt bewegung
ins berliner regierungsviertel politisch
rote fahren vor grüne den rhein auch
gelbe folgen treffen der voraussichtlich
neue ampel regierung mit der noch
geschäftsführenden kanzlerin vieles
spricht für eine weitere verschärfung im
kampf gegen korona die hinweise darauf
verdichten sich im laufe des tages
andrang vor einem impfzentrum in köln
und ein ministerpräsident
sichtlich genervt wer jetzt den knall
nicht gehört hat dem kann man nicht mehr
helfen dann müssen wir jetzt wirklich
kreativ sein und zu besseren lösungen
kommen um noch mehr menschen impfen zu
können anderen länderchefs aber recht
dass inzwischen nicht mehr aus sie
fordern im pflicht für alle es ist eben
eine frage ob viele millionen menschen
in ihrer feier dauerhaft beschränkt
werden müssen weil einige andere für
sich entscheiden dass er eine waffe aber
nicht machen gibt freiheit nur in
verantwortung und wir haben eben
verantwortung für alle und das müssen
wir gegeneinander abwägen und dann sind
wir zu dem ergebnis einer impfpflicht
gekommen natürlich gibt es eine spaltung
der gesellschaft ist doch keine frage
ich glaube dass eine impfpflicht am ende
so wie es immer war bei solchen
diskussionen
es gab auch schon in deutschland im
pflichten des dazu führte dass am ende
man ihr zusammen kommt weil es mal
entschieden ist lange sprachen sich die
anderen parteien eher für spezifische
impfpflicht aus also für bestimmte
berufe oder bestimmte einrichtungen das
scheint nun überholt
wenn sie kommt dann muss ich aber sitzen
und da muss sie insbesondere vor den
gerichten bestand haben und dafür ist
ein nachweis dass mildere mittel nicht
zur verfügung stehen sicherlich sehr
sinnvoll angesichts rasant steigender
inzidenz inhalten immer mehr
verfassungsexperten eine allgemeine
impfpflicht für zulässig die impfpflicht
kann in der jetzigen situation
eingeführt werden aber nicht zur
bekämpfung der vierten welle dafür ist
es zu spät aber als maßnahme gegen eine
zu erwartende fünfte welle es kommt
bewegung in die sache in welche richtung
man kann es ja
die richtung kann man ahnen theo koll es
so zu verstehen dass eine impfpflicht in
der politik immer mehr anhänger findet
oder ja der meinungs- schwerpunkt hat
sich deutlich verschoben richtung
impfpflicht bei der fdp ist der weg
glaube ich besonders weit daher
beschränkt sie sich noch auf eine
pflicht für die beschäftigten in alten-
und pflegeeinrichtungen die grünen
dagegen sind so ist zu hören auf dem weg
richtung allgemeine impfpflicht auch bei
der spd mehren sich solche stimmen
durchaus auch unterstützt von vielen
verfassungsrechtlern die eine
impfpflicht für vereinbar mit dem
grundgesetz halten und das wiederum
hilft der politik denn als so viele
übrigens ja auch die kanzlerin hatten
sich früh festgelegt dass es keine
impfpflicht geben würde
stichwort kanzlerin gab es ja noch
dieses treffen heute im kanzleramt was
was wird man dazu also offensichtlich
wurde die kanzlerin wirklich heute abend
relativ deutlich sie ist hochgradig
alarmiert und findet das neue corona
gesetz der ampel schlicht nicht
ausreichend auch deswegen hat sie ja die
spitzen der parteien regelrecht
einbestellt über den inhalt schweigen
zwar alle teilnehmer eisern aber klar
ist dass es angesichts der hoch
dramatischen lage einschneidender
maßnahmen geben muss entweder nutzt die
politik noch den morgigen letzten
gültigkeit tag der epidemischen notlage
und verabschiedet beispielsweise
ausgangssperren die dann übergangsweise
noch bis mitte dezember gelten dürfen
oder die ampel beschließt selbst
weitergehende maßnahmen wie sie
beispielsweise schon bei den grünen im
gespräch sind auch inklusive
ausgangssperren also allen scheint klar
zu sein dass dringender handlungsbedarf
besteht dankeschön nach berlin theo koll
den ministerpräsidenten hatte merkel ja
gestern schon geraten maßnahmen zu
ergreifen bevor diese juristisch
problematisch werden denn wie gesagt am
donnerstag läuft die epidemische lage
nationaler tragweite als rechtsgrundlage
aus kurz vor toresschluss sozusagen zog
dann heute auch thüringen nach und
verschärft seine corona maßnahmen unter
anderem mit einer nächtlichen
ausgangssperre für ungeimpfte
sperrstunden in der gastronomie und der
schließung von klubs schwimmbädern und
weihnachtsmärkten sachsen hatte ja
bereits ähnliche maßnahmen beschlossen
unsere reporterin manuela konrad
berichtet aus dem sächsischen
erzgebirgskreis dort sind die instanzen
besonders hoch und die impfquote
besonders niedrig
unterwegs im erzgebirge eine region die
stolz ist auf ihre bergbautradition
warum liegt die impfquote hierbei nur
knappen 45% warum gibt es hier so viele
im skeptiker in aue liegt die sieben
tages inzidenz heute bei
1600 das treibt viele zu den impfungen
sie stehen seit stunden in der schlange
es ist sehr kalt minus 3 grad die
regierung hätte halt eher reagieren
müssen die booster ist doch nichts neues
die meisten wollen hier eine booster
impfung manche aber wollen sich ihre
erste spritze ab
richtig ist habe ich abstand genommen oh
jetzt fest dass es nötig ist und nur bis
mich durch krumm auch paul hat es
geschafft der 18 jährige bekommt seine
erste impfung der zweig druck in sachsen
ist ihm einfach zu groß geworden
hauptsächlich dass ich wieder feiern
gehen kann besondere freiheiten habe ich
bin in meinem freundeskreis so ziemlich
der einzige so viele kinder hatten wir
einfach weil sie denken der impfstoff
werde mit guter form in aue ist die
der weihnachtsmarkt abgesagt manche
leute genervt von den harten corona
maßnahmen und zunehmendem druck der
landesregierung
um 8.40 uhr mit einem strick beide leute
da gehen die beide im raum auseinander
die wm haben wir meinen und das brauchen
wir nicht alles mit sich machen lassen
viele sagen das ist nicht richtig
ausgereift richtig untersucht worden und
deshalb sind sie dagegen wir können
etliche aber sie lassen sich auch nicht
überzeugen ich glaube dass die
impfskepsis
bis hin zur im verweigerung bei den
sachsen deswegen so stark ausgeprägt ist
weil zwei dinge zusammen kommen auf der
einen seite
das ergebnis einer längeren historischen
erfahrung die viele sechsten und sachsen
von der obrigkeit und staatlichen
institutionen und dem vertrauen in diese
institutionen entfernt hat
kulturelle prägung und politisches
protest verhalten wo viele
impfverweigerer sind sagt der
wissenschaftler gäbe es eine nähe zur
afg den oberbürgermeister von gebürtiger
hesse treibt die niedrige impfquote
unter seinen bürgern um von einer
impfpflicht aber hält er nichts also ich
befürchten eine impfpflicht gibt
tatsächlich hier und nicht nur hier aber
weitgehend hier nach hinten los weil
dann erst recht widerstand organisiert
wird und wenn man mit diesen leuten
spricht von der rechten szene sagen ja
die steilvorlagen werden hier geliefert
die suchen sie gar nicht die bekommen
sie geliefert und es sollte man
vermeiden
beim impfen um die ecke ist nach einer
dreiviertelstunde schon schluss nach 265
dosen viele auch erst impflinge müssen
enttäuscht gehen sachsen hat heute
angekündigt die impf teams massiv
auszubauen die höchsten corona zahlen
und die niedrigste impfquote der
freistaat muss handeln
um skepsis hat jedenfalls eine lange
tradition wie überhaupt viele aktuelle
pandemie phänomene historisch gesehen
die jobs sind schaut man in die
geschichtsbücher kann man sich die augen
reiben so viel kommt under bekannt vor
etwa die radikalen masken gegner während
der spanischen grippe oder im
neunzehnten jahrhundert das gerücht dass
die impfung mit kuhpocken beim menschen
genetische veränderungen auslösen könnte
die irrationale angst davor war bei
vielen größer als die angst vor einem
virus dass 30 prozent der infizierten
tötete und überlebende wirklich grausam
entstellt es lohnt sich jedenfalls der
blick in die vergangenheit wenn heute
wieder über eine impfpflicht gesprochen
wird dazu gleich noch ein interview mit
einem medizinhistoriker zuvor wirft
oliver reichert einen blick zurück auf
deutsche impfpflicht
im krieg 1870 71 preußen gegen
frankreich kam es zu einer großen
brocken epidemie die konsequenz
1874 wurde im deutschen kaiserreich eine
pflicht zur impfung gegen pocken
erlassen die erste impfung im zweiten
lebensjahr die wiederholungs impfung im
zwölften
mit solchen schock fotos machten
impfgegner mobil von gift war die rede
von selbstheilung und gesunder
lebensführung die impfgegner hielten
kongresse ab etwa 1911 in frankfurt am
main organisierten sich in vereinen
trotzdem überdauerte die impfpflicht den
lauf der zeit die republik von weimar
und auch den nationalsozialismus herz
der zehnte später als die welt für pocan
frei erklärt wurde endete auch die
impfpflicht in der jungen bundesrepublik
kam es abgesehen von der pocken hilft
nicht nur ganz vereinzelt zu regionalen
im verpflichtungen in der brd setzte man
auf freiwilligkeit
anders in der ddr hier galt impfen als
teil der staatsräson seit anfang der
60er jahre galt für etliche krankheiten
eine impfpflicht schon früh gegen ttc
dann gegen diphtherie tetanus polio
keuchhusten später gegen masern
1961 gab es in der ddr noch vier fälle
von polio in der brd vor allem im
ruhrgebiet erkranken dagegen tausende
hunderte starben dass deutschland hatte
auf einen impfstoff gesetz der injiziert
werden musste das wollten viele nicht
im osten gab es die schluckimpfung die
ddr bot der brd 3 millionen impfdosen an
der ersten diente ab aber auch hier
stellte man bald auf schluckimpfung um
mit einem serum aus dem westen
in den 70er und 80er jahren hatte die
ddr in sachen immunisierung wohl die
nase vorn auch wenn das impfen in ost
und west nur schwer vergleichbar ist
das impfen wurde im vereinigten
deutschland in die praxen der
niedergelassenen ärzte verlagert
verschwand aus den gesundheitsämtern das
hat die impf situation in deutschland
unübersichtlicher gemacht
der blick in die geschichte darüber
wollen wir mit dem historiker malte
thies entsprechen er ist professor für
geschichte
spezialisiert auf medizingeschichte hat
aktuell auch ein buch über die korona
pandemie geschrieben aber sich schon
lange davor mit der geschichte des
impfens befasst guten abend herr
professor diesen
namen slomka jemand zurück guckt in die
geschichte des impfens haben das gefühl
geschichte wiederholt sich vieles war
schon da auch in die skepsis oder auch
militante impfgegner gab es früher schon
zum beispiel in den 1800 70er jahren
also im neunzehnten jahrhundert als es
um die pocken ging man hat den eindruck
die brauchten damals gar kein internet
um sich zu finden und auch ein
verschwörungs mythen zu verbreiten
in der tat wenn man ein bisschen
zurückblickt dann bekommt auch so einige
déjà vu heute und ende des 19
jahrhunderts wird schon genau um das
gestritten um das wollte auch streiten
um die um die grundrechte wem gehört der
körper und eben auch über
verschwörungstheorien und genau was sie
sagen die echo kann man das internet die
wir heute so bedauern die gibt es damals
genauso auf demonstration auf impfgegner
zeitschriften also auch da eigene
öffentlichkeiten mit denen man eben
gegen das impfen sich dann zur wehr
setzt und es gab versuche anreize zu
schaffen also zum beispiel mit brezeln
auf volksfesten wer sich gegen die
pocken impfen lässt das fand ich auch
relativ faszinierend
ja es wurde lange darum gestritten was
der bessere weg ist ist es sozialer
druck ist es die pflicht oder sind es
eben anreize und am ende des 19
jahrhunderts gewinnt dann der soziale
druck die impfpflicht wird für das ganze
deutsche reich erklärt und damit ist
sozusagen erstmal die maßgabe sozusagen
der autoritäre interventionen staat gibt
sozusagen den ton an und das sorgt dann
wiederum oder verschärft meiner
wahrnehmung nach auch die kritik dann
nochmal ordentlich also würden sie
erster historischen sich eine
impfpflicht für problematisch halten
also problematisch ist aber eher davon
abraten
also in der tat ist das impfen sozusagen
es wirklich die errungenschaft der
medizin des 1920 als ohne frage und dass
wir heute so leben können wir überleben
foucault entschuldigung das verdanken
wir im programm und machen bio ticker
ich bin trotzdem skeptisch ob die
impfpflicht der königsweg ist die
impfpflicht hat durchaus vorzüge sie
schafft infrastrukturen im 19
jahrhundert das erste mal dass impfen
kommt sozusagen überall an im ganzen
deutschen reich das ist gut aber es
mobilisiert dann auch erst recht den
widerstand bei den impfgegnern sowieso
aber selbst bei denen die sich
vielleicht impfen lassen würden aber die
jetzt sorge haben vor dem totalen
gesundheits start und ein zweites
problemen der impfpflicht ist dass man
sich verdeckte infektionsherde reihen
schaffte die impfpflicht führt nämlich
dazu dass plötzlich der handel mit
gefälschten ausweisen floriert und dann
gibt es plötzlich überall im haus rocken
ausbrüche und eigentlich dachte man ist
doch jetzt durchgehend immun
das gab es damals auch schon bei den
pocken dass das was gefälscht wurde ja
also tatsächlich ist das ein klarer
zusammenhang ein historischer
perspektive deutlich wird je höher der
druck desto eher die umwege und auswege
die gesucht werden und ja es gibt damals
die impfausweise und im zeugnisse und
die werden dann genauso gefälscht wie
heute als auch da kann man leider aus
der geschichte ein stück weit lernen
interessant ist auch dass es städte wie
dresden und stuttgart also der
schwäbische baden württembergischen raum
schon im neunzehnten jahrhundert als
geht als hochburgen der impfgegner
galten welche strömungen oder was hat
dazu beigetragen
in der tat ist das ganz interessant in
den stuttgarter warum im dresdner raum
da sammelt sich das was man damals die
lebensreformbewegung
nennt das sind naturheilkundliche
strömungen esoterische anthroposophische
strömungen da wird sozusagen mobil
gemacht gegen die moderne die moderne
die als industrialisierung urbanisierung
eindringt in die lebenswelt und das wird
sozusagen scharf bekämpft insbesondere
mit einem rückkehr zur natürlichen
lebensweise wie es heißt und da ist das
impfen natürlich das paradebeispiel das
impfen bezahlen kann als symbol für die
moderne schlechthin genommen und
verteufelt und für die
nationalsozialisten galt das impfen als
paradebeispiel für die jüdische
schulmedizin
genau wobei es umso schlimmer ist dass
diese jüdische schulmedizin und die
antisemitischen vorwürfe eine ganz lange
tradition haben schon im 19 jahrhundert
wird gewettert gegen die die gegen das
impfen als vergiftung des volkskörpers
wie es damals schon heißt im dritten
reich bekommt das natürlich nochmal
enormen aufschwung aber das hat in
deutschland eine sehr sehr lange
tradition diese antisemitischen
stereotypen und verschwörungstheorien
bis hin zu titeln auf dem matchblatt
stürmer dass die deutsche mutter doch
vor angst vom imf arzt haben sollte also
vieles wiederholt sich könnten jetzt
noch lange lange drüber reden aber
leider bin ich mir die zeitweilig ein
nächstes mal professor tiefen danken für
das gespräch und russland
noch mehr hintergründe zum thema impfen
und zu corona pandemie allgemein finden
sie wie immer bei uns online auf zdf
heute dass in deutschland die pandemie
derart außer kontrolle geraten ist wird
im ausland mit verwunderung beobachtet
und das hat auch folgen kaiser ja zum
beispiel warnen die usa jetzt vor einer
einreise ins bundesgebiet die us
seuchenschutzbehörde und das
us-außenministerium setzten den
reisehinweis wir deutschland auf die
höchste stufe als ähnlich gefährlich
schätzen die usa nur fünf weitere eu
staaten ein darunter belgien österreich
und die niederlande für kinder unter
zwölf jahren gibt es in der eu bislang
keinen zugelassenen impfstoff am
donnerstag nun will die
arzneimittelbehörde ema über eine
empfehlung entscheiden
dabei geht es um den impfstoff von
beyond advisor in israel werden seit
heute kinder ab fünf jahren
flächendeckend geimpft ebenfalls mit dem
bayer-werk 7 sie bekommen ein drittel
der erwachsenen dosis in kanada gab es
dafür vergangenen freitag grünes licht
in den usa sogar schon vor drei wochen
seit jahren ringt die eu um eine
neuausrichtung ihrer agrarpolitik nun
hat das eu parlament für die
ausgehandelte reform gestimmt mit den
änderungen soll die landwirtschaft
umwelt verträglicher und gerechter
werden so sind künftig fördermittel für
landwirte stärker an umweltauflagen
geknüpft kritikern geht die reform nicht
weit genug als letzte müssen nur noch
die mitgliedsstaaten zustimmen was als
formsache gilt
die zahl der angezeigten gewalttaten
unter paaren steigt seit jahren an im
vergangenen jahr
stark laut dem bundeskriminalamt
registrierten die behörden 2020 mehr als
148 tausend opfer und damit 44 prozent
mehr als im vorjahr bei den meisten
fällen und 79 prozent ging die gewalt
von männern aus die sich die korona
pandemie auswirkte ist unklar denn
wahrscheinlich wurden während des schah
uns weniger fälle entdeckt und gemeldet
überhaupt geht man bei gewalt in
partnerschaften von einer hohen
dunkelziffer aus
wie sie sich im konflikt mit belarus
schlägt wird für die eben über die
aktuelle krise hinaus folgen haben es
ist ein exempel ob es einem benachbarten
diktator gelingt die europäer
auseinander zu dividieren und zu
erpressen und da schaut auf moskau vom
feldherrenhügel aus aufmerksam zu
entsprechend groß ist der druck auf die
eu-kommission die gegenwert zu
organisieren und den eigenen laden
zusammenzuhalten
welche pläne brüssel heute dazu
präsentierte berichtet gunnar krüger
schneeballschlacht in einem hybriden
krieg so beschreibt die eu die lager in
ihrer außengrenze einen wie sah man
schafik nennt sie einen migranten oder
auch eine waffe der 23-jährige zeit wo
er schläft ein logistikzentrum als
wärmehalle eine krise auf lager für
diese reise habe ich mein ganzes geld
ausgegeben 4000 dollar die eu kommission
sieht in der krise ein drama aufgeführt
von belarus und gibt dem parlament heute
ihre antwort ganz oben eine schwarze
liste für dubiose reiseunternehmen
es gibt tatsächlich spezialisierten
reisebüros die das ganze paket anbieten
von visum über den flug zum hotel und
ganz schön zynisch das taxi oder den bus
bis zur grenze dagegen müssen wir
wirklich vorgehen
zusätzlich gibt die eu geld für den
grenzschutz in polen lettland und
litauen 150 millionen euro drei mal mehr
als bisher für die humanitäre hilfe der
un in belarus
700.000 euro für die rückführung per
charter und für starthilfen 3,5
millionen das parlament muss diesem
paket noch zustimmen und es hat seine
schmerzgrenzen
das ist keine migrations krise das ist
ein hybrider krieg wir christdemokraten
können keine art von deal mit
lukaschenko zustimmen er das problem
geschaffen er muss schuss löst
und doch hilft die eu auch finanziell
etwa als letzte woche über 400 iraker
zurück flogen doch 15.000 migranten
halten sich nach schätzungen noch in
belarus auf sie sind die krise auf lager
menschen ausgeliefert eine machthaber
und seinem zynismus
ihr wunsch ist uns befehl für die die
zurückwollen startern wir einen flug
aber es müssen eben genug seien viele
wollen einfach nicht nach hause
deutschland solle 2000 menschen derzeit
aufnehmen gemischte botschaften die an
der grenze die hoffnung auf sparflamme
halten
ich habe vor nichts angst
nichts ist gelöst an europas
außengrenzen wenn belarus will dann
flammt der konflikt wieder auf
für das chinesische regime kam der fall
der tennisspielerin kommt zur unzeit
drei monate vor der eröffnung der
olympischen winterspiele in peking es
schien ihnen die junge frau mit ihren
anschuldigungen gegen einen politiker
wohl als lästige nestbeschmutzerin sie
einfach mundtot zu machen und im
wahrsten sinne des wortes von der
bildfläche zu nehmen ist dann das
typische verfahren nur hatte man wohl
nicht mit dem internationalen aufschrei
gerechnet den ihr verschwinden auslöste
videos von ihr sollten dann für ruhe
sorgen auch das gelang nicht dafür
wirkten die filmchen zu inszeniert also
legte peking nach mit hilfe des ioc auf
dessen top funktionäre ist verlass und
voller berichtet
wo ist branche fragt sich die ganze welt
warum wird ihren vorwürfen des sexuellen
missbrauchs nicht nachgegangen ein mann
hätte aufklärung verlangen können thomas
bach der präsident des ioc
stattdessen wird er zum werkzeug der
chinesischen propaganda
er durfte mit dir sprechen wir sehen ihn
von hinten vielleicht lächelt sie
lächelt zurück im hintergrund stofftiere
inszenierte normalität
[Musik]
das ioc scheint es nicht im geringsten
zu interessieren ob sie frei ist ob sie
einen anwalt oder ein prozess bekommt ob
sie das land verlassen will
später lässt bach erklären sei sicher
wohlauf zu den vorwürfen des sexuellen
missbrauchs kein wort stattdessen lädt
er sie zum abendessen ein
alle frauen chinas bekommen hier eine
botschaft thomas bach hilft beim
verschleiern ihnen wird gesagt vergesst
einfach den fall von 2
bio c präsident bach und der chinesische
präsident she es geht um viel in dieser
beziehung sie bekommt sein olympischen
winterspiele und kann so die
überlegenheit des chinesischen systems
feiern bach und das ioc verdienen geld
und schweigen da für
sie können menschenrechts probleme nicht
lösen die generationen von politikern
nicht fähig waren zu lösen
der fall porsche schafft aufmerksamkeit
er wirft schon jetzt einen schatten auf
die olympischen winterspiele
chinas machthaber drohen deshalb nach
dem gespräch von bach mit pong schweiz
müsse mit der kritik schluss sein
ich will eindeutig klarstellen es ist
keine sache die das ausland etwas angeht
in wenigen monaten sollen die
olympischen winterspiele beginnen bunte
bilder statt graue bilder aus den
arbeitslagern in jinyan die
sinnhaftigkeit der spiele wird nun immer
lauter in frage
stimmen von spitzenpolitikern der grünen
fordern einen diplomatischen boykott wir
müssen das nicht gutheißen in dem
vertreter der bundesregierung vertreter
des bundestages daran als ehrengäste
teilnehmen und dem quasi dann ein
gütesiegel verleihen und deswegen ist
die forderung ganz klar diplomatischen
boykott der olympischen spiele in peking
was punk zwei widerfahren ist wird wohl
nie aufgeklärt der deutsche thomas bach
hatte die chance dazu aber das ist wohl
gegen seinen olympischen geist
und jetzt nochmal meldungen von kaiser
richter einer der größten anleger
prozesse deutschlands ist wahrscheinlich
bald zu ende nach 20 jahren streit hat
die deutsche telekom rund 16.000 klägern
einen vergleich angeboten und das
oberlandesgericht frankfurt hat ihnen
die annahme empfohlen im jahr 2000
hatten die kleinaktionäre geld verloren
weil der telekom kurs direkt nach dem
dritten börsengang abstürzte sie werfen
dem unternehmen vor im
wertpapierprospekt die risiken nicht
ausreichend benannt zu haben
von der energiewende wollen auch
deutschlands große stromversorger
profitieren und dafür nehmen sie jetzt
sehr viel geld in die hand heute kündigt
der e.on massive investitionen an wie
zuvor schon rwe 27 milliarden sollen vor
allem in den netzausbau fließen valerie
haller an der börse warum investiert der
energieriese ausgerechnet dort ja weil
netze in zukunft mehr benötigt werden
denn je in deutschland aber auch in
europa sind sie jetzt schon an den
belastungsgrenzen angelangt und der
bedarf wird ja immer größer viele
menschen dürften in den kommenden jahren
noch weit mehr strom brauchen für e
autos wärmepumpen so viel in unserem
leben ist inzwischen akku betrieben aber
auch die industrie wird immer
stromhungrige zum beispiel durch
batterie oder chip fabriken und
rechenzentren in europa wird in zukunft
immer mehr grüner strom fließen e.on
will davon profitieren muss aber erstmal
kräftig investieren e.on hat fast keine
großkraftwerk der letzte atommeiler
stellt kommendes jahr den betrieb ein er
und verkauft strom und gas und betreibt
vor allem netze in deren ausbau soll nun
das meiste geld fließen hinzu kommt der
ausbau für millionen wärmepumpen und
batteriespeicher auch rund 5000 neue
schnelllade punkte sind geplant die
energiewende löst nicht nur bei e.on
eine investitionsoffensive aus auch rwe
steckt milliarden in den ausbau grünen
stroms viel geld will auch enbw-
investieren insgesamt zwölf milliarden
doch die anleger von den
milliarden-investitionen zu überzeugen
ist nicht einfach eon aktien verlieren
heute deutlich insgesamt wird die
energiewende eine herkulesaufgabe nicht
nur für eon und wir stehen erst am
anfang vielen dank valerie in der
fußball champions league feiert bayern
münchen den fünften sieg im fünften
gruppenspiel mit einem 2 2 1 bei dynamo
kiew auf dem schneebedeckten rasen traf
lewandowski und kuba und bescherten den
bayern damit den vorzeitigen gruppensieg
das zdf darf sich über einen wichtigen
preis von intendant thomas bellut wurde
mit dem international emmy award
gewürdigt überreicht wurde die
auszeichnung von basketball star dirk
nowitzki
bellut sagte in seiner dankesrede er sei
in der glücklichen position gewesen ohne
druck von behörden oder regierungen
arbeiten zu können er widme den preis
all den journalisten weltweit die nicht
frei berichten können
der schauspieler volker lechtenbrink
stand für tangro und talente nun ist er
im alter von 77 jahren gestorben
an den folgen einer schweren krankheit
seinen großen durchbruch feierte er
bereits mit 14 jahren mit seiner rolle
im oscar prämierten tricks kammer die
brücke es folgten mehr als 100 weitere
filme und fernsehen und dieser beruf hat
mich wahnsinnig glücklich gemacht
hat mich ausgefüllt
hat mich gereizt hat mich wach gehalten
vielleicht auch deshalb weil volker
lechtenbrink seinem beruf so vielseitig
lebte auch als regisseur
theater-intendant oder sehen
[Musik]
die noble
das war es von uns in der reportage
reihe 37 grad geht es gleich um eine
ungewöhnliche frau deren berufes ist
sowohl den anfang als auch das ende des
lebens zu begleiten
wir wünschen einen schönen abend und
empfehlen ihnen noch das heute-journal
update wie christopher wehrmann um 3
nach 2 auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter hoher luftdruck
war wetter bestimmt heute über
deutschland und so war es relativ ruhig
ein weiteres hoch dehnt sich aus über
dem atlantik und so stellt sich eine
regionale nördliche strömung ein also
mehr regional in diesem sinne von nord
nach süd und dann kommt kalte luft in
den nächsten tagen und sogar etwas
schnee dazu wir schauen auf das wetter
in der nacht da gibt es nach norden
viele wolken aber es bleibt trocken im
süden bildet sich nebel teilweise klart
es auf und dann gehen die temperaturen
in den frostbereich zurück null grad
richtung main und minus sieben grad am
alpenrand am mildesten an der nordsee
mit plus 8 grad morgen gibt es dann dort
vor allem viele wolken und etwas regen
oder sprühregen seien generell in der
nordhälfte viele wolken nach süden hin
deutlich freundlicher und sogar längere
zeit sonnenschein die temperaturen
erreichen höchstwerte von 1 bis 6 grad
im süden und neun bis zehn grad richtung
nordsee die nächsten tage am donnerstag
dann im norden regen sonst trocken und
sogar ein bisschen sonnenschein bei
minus 1 bis 9 grad ein noch relativ
ruhiger tag und am freitag kommt im
süden dann schnee auf der dann
hauptsächlich am alpenrand und in bayern
für eine schneedecke sorgen wird im
norden dann viele wolken und etwas regen
- ein bis sechs grad und samstag vor
allem der westhälfte regen und schnee
eine schöne art